трах опитування приватні багата продав і до
хвилиною ще більшу про плани на мої
будні і так можна коротко
охарактеризувати через його
прем'єр-міністра України Володимира
гройсмана за піцу кому rock you would
увальня була у його заявок і на точності
засіки пробурити нехай грудьми
про закони 1000 створа на сьогодні вся
законодавства для боротьби з корупцією
валяються
навіть серйозні кров тури ціни зовсім
так у хвала не щини в сильну яким
незаконний наприклад
антикорупційне бюро до 7 травня
проводять операції під прикриттям про
чутка про виведення цього фону
перехідного етапу ведений дня.
antique у риб тіні органи зате ми
подавали всю вам інфраструктуру в
ефективної боротьби з корупцією на законі
набу спеціалізованому так сильно
прокуратура на ведучій годині води
реформа суднової системи ви тут сперечаєтеся
для ефективної боротьби з корупцією у
його 100 чаю ключового моменту він тільки
рук then обговоривши
новий закон процедуру стрі впав на рахунку
рик перрі два чаю створа не густіша
антикорупційного суду
3 потрібно хвали то україном закон один
з меморандумом з МВФ труби цього ланцюга ви
не проти доступних двох місяців
німа прогресу в створ і не служби
фінансових спадщин
також повноцінно навпаки і реєстр
електронних декларацій про початок
боротьби з корупцією
за брата раки україна малого дочірні ви
так ще до корупції алла ніхто на
навожу зовсім боротися за раз слухає
розгойдувалася боротьба на кшталт паски рубки і
use нову владу розгойдалася 2014 уроки у
хвала ним ключового закону про
залякування корупції, проте тим уроки
парламент тисячі загиблих закон smooth
корупції в рамочку організації
skoda вотана хто не доктора ти і
з розкручування волоки поправкою і
назвала їх піскам на такий рук then
організації про перехожого нею залишки
все абсолютно
неадекватно з абсолютно нечесно та c
принесла вакули політик в Україні
брудиться прахова ти свої ставки св
спосіб жити а хороми столітті фон і там
живуть і тоді один із розслідуванням
радіо свободи сам прем'єр мишкою в
квартирі в елітному кварталі
новопечерські лаври біля центру Києва
яка формула на ялинку пенсіонерку
вибачте один з реєстру мій нових
правду на травень 2 квартири на тому є у
декларації прем'єра призначена своєю
непорушності
у них він і моя прем'єр моя рація калуга
місто що в Україні створа nicula поза
органи для прохання з корупцією проте на
все пред'явлення прем'єр околиця
зажадаєш чини оповіді комірник змін
активну гриф це незалежної роботи
андо коло тину організм